when I was at my dad's liquor store at
32 32 and my friends from high school
and college came to buy wine and liquor
and I would ring them up at the register
and bring the case of wine to their BMW
because they worked in Wall Street I saw
what they looked at I know what judgment
looks like yeah yeah facts yeah well you
also had a bit blow up too it's easy to
pick it up yeah but but but but you know
what attention is the number one asset
when you have the glow up in your head
that you've already been glown right
because you're just in your Zone
regardless if you get to the place you
got to or not like I wish people knew
how happy I was then in that moment if
people fall in love with the process
like actually and I don't know I feel
like I'm in some weird next level of
this video game where I almost like like
when it's not working more yeah my great
dream is that the world redefines
success